sanders al infinito y más allá
quisiera empezar preguntándoles qué es
lo primero que sienten cuando ven esta
imagen
a la edad de 10 años mis padres me
regalaron una enciclopedia y en esa
enciclopedia la imagen que más me
impactó fue la del planeta tierra y
justamente esta imagen se ha quedado
supongo de mi subconsciente durante
todos estos años porque luego decidí
estudiar biología en la universidad el
pregrado y bueno en el posgrado estoy
estudiando biología molecular
para mí esta imagen significa un hogar
el hogar no solamente de nosotros los
seres humanos sino de las plantas de los
animales de los microorganismos
acompañado de todos los factores
abióticos que existen
parece al majestuoso tan grandioso pero
si lo observamos de lejos
un planeta nada más el tercer planeta
del sistema planetario soler pero uno en
una millonésima de planetas en el
espacio
y se ve así pequeño y tan indefenso tan
vulnerable
y bueno con esta idea complemento
también que el ser humano ha querido
salir de su hogar del cne está tierra y
buscar otros lugares en el espacio
buscando vida
preguntándose existirá solamente la vida
en el planeta tierra oeste la vida
también existe en otros planetas seremos
los únicos del universo qué tipo de
vidas existirá el martes por ejemplo
y gracias al avance de la tecnología es
que el humano finalmente salió de su
hogar y ha podido tomar fotografías
impresionantes del planeta para poder
llegar a marte con el robot conocidísimo
el curiosity
y es así que en las agencias espaciales
se ha desarrollado una ciencia a estas
se llama la astrobiología que estudian
la biología
o sea estudiar sobre mi núcleo dije no
la vida en el espacio pero no solamente
en el espacio sino también en la tierra
porque para estudiar la vida en el
universo tenemos que conocer la vida en
la tierra
cómo se originó la vida cuál es el
futuro de la vida y para eso cómo
evoluciona la vida qué tipo de vida que
existen cuáles son los límites
físico-químicos de esta y bueno yo me
interesé bastante en ello no solamente
me quedé en ser bióloga sino dije voy a
prepararme más quiero hacer astrobióloga
todavía no lo logro porque creo que es
una carrera de largo camino
fui al 10 showmatch desert stereo
station como astronauta de simulación
como creo yo bailo triste y lo que hacía
era básicamente ir a campo recolectar
las muestras y estudiar las más un
enfoque biológico de laboratorio también
fui a la escuela mexicana de
astrobiología y todo esto me sirvió para
conocer a un grupo de amigos en aquella
época
estudiantes previos pero que sean tres
universitarios con los que nos reuníamos
a leer artículos científicos cada fin de
semana para nosotros era una actividad
muy reconfortante porque aprendíamos lo
que en las misiones espaciales del mundo
se estaban realizando
y fundamos la sociedad científica de
astrobiología del perú
aprendimos que la astrobiología se puede
estudiar observando los planetas
buscando aquellos planetas que se
parecen a la tierra buscando planetas
que tengan una estrella así como la
nuestra pero también se podría estudiar
mediante los microorganismos que
existían aquí en la tierra pero en
condiciones que se parecían mucho a las
de otros planetas condiciones como por
ejemplo la el gran rango de temperatura
al que podrían sobrevivir temperaturas
extremas pedazos extremos actividad de
agua donde hasta ahora no se había
encontrado vida como por ejemplo 0.6 de
actividad de agua
y luego nos volvemos todavía más amigos
y fundamos o formamos la agrupación
llamada t inc y el habla y ya quiere
decir luna en quechua y bueno la
laboratorio
postulamos a un concurso internacional
llamado la laboratorio de la luna todos
los miembros éramos de diferentes
carreras buscamos apoyo por supuesto de
profesionales que ya tenían experiencia
en estas áreas en especial en el doctor
valdivia nuestro asesor y fundador
también de la sociedad de astrología del
perú
y fuimos a universidades en la agencia
especial en perú a varios laboratorios a
pedir su apoyo en esta idea muy difícil
en el contexto peruano por supuesto pero
aún así seguimos fuimos a la india
expusimos como semifinalista luego
llegamos a ser finalistas y finalmente
debemos de ser ganadores uno de los
siete ganadores nuestra propuesta
consistía en enviar un mini laboratorio
con bacterias que pueden sobrevivir
condiciones del espacio pero hay tantas
condiciones que solamente nos vamos a
enfocar ninguna crean la radiación
extrema la radiación ultravioleta y
bueno pensamos que el micrones nos
llevaríamos que me de organismo pueden
sobrevivir estas condiciones tan
extremas justo 2017
recuerdan que estábamos buscando mucha
información en la web y encontramos sale
una noticia de que en 2017 desde ya hace
mucho tiempo los reportes desde el 2008
hasta el 2017 se había reportado que el
perú tenía la mayor el mayor índice de
radiación ultravioleta y luego nos dimos
cuenta buscando más información que los
antes tenían el mayor impacto de
radiación ultravioleta y justo sobre uno
está el debilitamiento de la capa de
ozono
entonces vamos a buscar allá y fuimos a
las lagunas altas vidas a los bofedales
a buscar qué tipo de microorganismos
sobreviven en estos ambientes y claro
están lesionaba ctc herias pero que si
una bacteria después nos vamos por la
escena bacterias que forman biopelículas
aquellas que tienen la capacidad todavía
mayor de poder sobrevivir en forma
pigmentos protectores contra la
radiación ultravioleta para protegerse
para filtrar las pero también proteínas
para formar biopelículas para estar
juntas y evitar la desecación en el
tiempo
fuimos a las lagunas latinas y no
solamente eso sino que complementamos
nuestra investigación haciendo nuestro
mini laboratorio espacial del cual ya
poseemos una patente
pero no nos quedamos ahí sino que la
investigación continúa
y nos dimos cuenta que estas bacterias
también pueden ser indicadores de algo
que ellas están sobreviviendo durante
todo ese tiempo
del calentamiento global
y cómo podríamos identificarlas desde el
punto de vista biológico que es el área
a la que pertenezco mediante la proteína
que están expresando para ayudarlas a
sobrevivir a estas condiciones pero hay
muchas maneras por ahí podríamos decir
la proteína que interviene en la
síntesis de los pigmentos o en la
formación de biopelículas es un estudio
que todavía estamos realizando pero nada
de esto hubiera pasado si es que no nos
hubiéramos atrevido y postular a un
concurso internacional que quizá la
mayoría diría porque los peruanos van a
postular a un concurso espacial
y nosotros lo hicimos porque es nuestro
sueño y es así que obtuvimos el apoyo no
solamente de concytec de la universidad
nacional ingeniería de promi patronato
uni de la ocde -que la universidad
católica acción pablo también carta de
apoyo de lanaja y finalmente un fondo
adicional de inversiones yo gráfica
eso es todo lo que les traigo realmente
mi mensaje es que así como los andes al
inicio nos dieron la papa nos dieron los
primeros alimentos para dar que los
incas sobrevivieran hoy también pueden
darnos algas microalgas en este caso
cianobacterias para que el hombre en el
espacio también
[Aplausos]